i stopped doing crossfit about i
remember seven years ago doing it six
years ago
we had he was working out we had this
big time trainer and i go yeah what
should you do crossfit and brendan
looked at me and goes
none of us do crossfit
and i was like it's it's that's not
that's where you're getting injured yeah
and remember when i did i was doing
olympic weightlifting yeah i was doing
olympic weightlifting with a coach and
he's doing like snatches brennan was
like dude i'm just telling you and i
remember i lit i did one thing and i
could feel
like a ti and i went oh
if i had done a little heavier i'd be
crippled now i could feel it i was like
in your back you got to be you got to be
your technique has to be flawless yeah
and you see crossfit like you're doing
so many reps yeah yeah technique but
cross if you can get crossfit it's a
great [ __ ] word these people are all
all those [ __ ]
i was doing in venice too and then i did
for like four or five weeks and i was
like man i just here's the problem one
day you're going to be a little tired
and your form is going to lag and you're
going to dead lift for time boom my my
my oh i love crossfit but
here's a place where every crossfit
they're always injured my my my
impression of every samoan guy is you
think i'm big you should see my brother
okay yeah here's my impression of every
crossroads person yeah i'm getting back
into it i pulled a little ever
now that i think about i used to know so
many people that would do crossfit now i
don't really know anyone that does it no
it used to be like a huge yeah it used
to be so massive there's people that are
getting the crossfit games and [ __ ]
right it's not on espn but i don't know
those people on a different level yeah
this is also a different [ __ ] speech
yes well they would say no
sure bring up they're not on supplements
bring up the crosstalk just take a look
at take a look because they were all
like talking about how they don't do any
it's all natural they probably get
tested yeah once again no they don't
it's like
just kidding you take a look at what
they look like you're like we got to be
a little bit more i mean they're still
monsters yeah they they still are even
if you did all the stories you'd never
be close to what they are
but some of these some of them are just
so thick it's hilarious fish on earth is
fair to say look at them they're oh my
god oh my god yeah
i did those competitors [ __ ] don't kid
yourself they're such athletes monsters
you don't like when i say athletes
it's tough they're very fit let's put it
there they're they're in crazy shape
yeah and they're very good at crossfit
yes oh look at them cover chest very
damn and but like i'll see people that
uh go to their insane i'm like skipping
people like no i'm not good
like to get to compete in that you got
to be crazy like rich frowning in those
people look at that look at that oh my
god
yeah that so she was an olympic uh
weightlifter yeah that's natural but
there's still there's
that's natural she's
right but she's still a freak yeah yeah
they're almost it's not
they're they're monsters there you go
that's that's well why what oh my god so
she was an olympic one why wouldn't you
get on [ __ ] if that like that's what
you're you're going to do yeah
yeah like do as many reps as you can
so that's the concept of crossfit do as
many reps as yeah that black guy is our
cartoon
they're all jacked as [ __ ] i know the
girl's legs are so big they're thighs
and ass yeah it's a whole different
level well those those girls are from
iceland the icelandic i mean there's
americans too yes
but yeah
there's a lot of americans iceland
they're there wait go down there there
she is the one on the middle one the
little iceland where and there's torah's
daughter torres daughter i think that's
she's she's been a winner yeah her name
is thor's daughter thor's daughter
um she is a [ __ ] she won yeah don't
make that face with you she won right
there
yes
i find her very attractive actually i
was just going to say that that is your
speed man yeah i'm way too light in the
ass huge dude she's a hell of an athlete
she was homeless i think she had
represented australia in the olympics
for powerlifting or something i thought
crossfit is crossfit's in the olympics
uh
there's something
so that one there there are the
champions wow right there those those
women are yeah ninja turtle labs yeah
dude you're talking about two both of
them are from iceland a tiny part of the
world where they have these
well they care about grass so you were
you were just doing one you just did one
day
i just did fran i just did a workout
uh-huh yeah there you go now i remember
i used to get nervous for crossfit
because you know you're gonna go through
so much pain oh my god yeah you're gonna
suffer
didn't you get nervous when you were
trained though you had that one trainer
when you were doing mma who would kill
you
tony jeffries no but you'd make me run
like a [ __ ] miles and miles and
miles
but you got another trainer i feel like
a strength and conditioning coach
lauren was tough yeah lauren's tough
lauren's really